LOREENA LEE: All right.
Hi, everyone.
Good afternoon.
My name is Loreena Lee.
I'm an engineer on
the Gmail team.
I've been working recently on
performance mostly and taking
a good look at how much memory
Gmail's been using.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm John McCutchan.
I'm part of Chrome Dev Rel.
And my focus is also on
performance and memory usage.
LOREENA LEE: So today we're
going to cover everything from
memory management basics
to garbage collection.
And we're going to introduce
some tools and techniques to
help you understand how much
memory your app is using.
So why is this important?
A lot of times when people talk
about performance versus
memory, performance wins
9 times out of 10.
And this is the trade-off
that people usually say,
performance versus memory?
Let's go ahead and
use more memory.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the idea
being that the more memory you
use the better the
performance is?
LOREENA LEE: Right.
So generally, if your caching
more, you're keeping more
resident memory, you have less
fetches to disk, so your
performance is usually
improved.
And so people were starting
to say that Gmail was
using a lot of memory.
We started hearing a lot of
anecdotes of people having a
Gmail tab that's using
a whole gig of mem.
And that seems kind of a lot.
But a lot about the same time
were like, well, who cares?
You have a ton of memory.
Memory's cheap.
Why not just use it?
But the time of our users
is very important.
So if they're spending two to
three seconds waiting for
their app to be responsive,
that's not good.
We don't want to waste
their time.
So we'll start using a little
bit more memory, start caching
a little bit more, help them
to get things to be more
responsive.
But at the same time, what's
worse than having your users
wait two to three seconds?
Having your app crash.
So this is the "He's
Dead, Jim" sad tab.
And a lot of you have probably
seen this before.
This is the Chrome sad tab.
And the "He's dead, Jim" variety
almost always comes as
an out of memory situation.
So we were starting to hear more
and more stories about
Gmail running out of memory and
people getting sad tabs
because of Gmail.
But we didn't really have
any data to know
how common this was.
Our colleagues were telling us,
oh, my Gmail ran out of
memory again, caused my
browser to crash.
But we didn't know if this is
something that was only
happening to people we knew.
Our power users were having
this situation, but our
parents weren't really
complaining.
But they only get a couple
mails a day or a
week, in some cases.
They probably spend a few
minutes on Gmail.
Whereas people at Google tend
to spend all day, getting
several hundred messages
a day.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
A few emails a minute.
LOREENA LEE: But we didn't
have any scientific data.
We only had anecdotes.
We had a bunch of tools that
didn't necessarily scale up to
things like applications
as big as Gmail.
We didn't really know how to
track what was leaking.
We didn't know how to
find the problems.
And so we kind of were starting
from nothing.
So I'm talking a little bit
about Gmail right now.
But really, this problem
is universal.
Running out of memory
is something that
everyone can encounter.
And you should care.
Because I don't know how much
you know about the Chrome
process model, but this isn't
just Gmail's problem.
So if you see here, I have
a ton of tabs open.
And Chrome will normally try to
open all of these tabs in
their own renderer process, but
that's not always possible.
So Chrome has a hard
limit on how many
processes it will fork.
And once you've exhausted that
limit, it will start putting
multiple tabs in a process.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So do you mean
if Gmail uses a lot of memory
or some pages a lot of memory,
it might kill five pages?
LOREENA LEE: Right.
So if all of these pages are
in the same process, that's
why a lot of times if you do
see this out of memory
situation with the sad tab
you'll notice several of them
at the same time.
It's not just one tab
that's crashing.
It's all of them that are
in that same process.
So this is something that
everyone needs to care about,
not just Gmail, not just your
app, but anyone who ends up in
the same process as your
app will care as well.
Just like anyone who ends up in
the same process as Gmail
will probably be glad that we
are making some effort to
reduce the amount of memory
that we're using.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right.
But before we can tackle
Gmail's problem, it's
important that we go back to
basics and understand both the
conceptual concepts for memory
management in JavaScript as
well as the practical with
V8 in particular.
So let's first talk about a high
level understanding of
how memory is managed
inside JavaScript.
So the questions I want you to
be able to answer after this
set of slides is, what types
of values are there in
JavaScript?
How are they organized
in memory?
What is garbage?
And what is a leak?
These are really basic
questions.
And I'm sure a lot of you know
the answers to these already.
But it's important that we have
really good definitions
of what these are so that we
can understand both the
problem and the tools.
So JavaScript has very
few value types.
There's booleans, there's
numbers, there's strings,
there's objects, and then
there's external data.
And so you'll know that there's
no arrays here.
And that's actually because
JavaScript as a language
doesn't have arrays.
They're built on top of the
objects inside JavaScript.
The keys are just the indexes
into the array.
But this is it.
This is all that
JavaScript has.
And the way they're organized
in memory is in a graph.
You'll see here this
blue node here.
And this is a root node.
This is outside of your
application's control, think
document or window.
This is created by
the browser.
It's in there as long as your
page is loaded, and you really
can't do anything with it
other than maybe add
properties to it.
From root nodes, there's
object nodes.
And these are JavaScript
objects.
And they're the only nodes which
can actually reference
other values inside the graph.
Terminating the graph are scaler
nodes, like a boolean
or a number.
These values cannot reference
other values inside the graph.
So this is it.
This is how memory is organized
inside JavaScript,
and this is what you, as a
programmer, can observe.
You have root notes, which are
outside of your control,
objects, which you can extend
and reference other values,
and then the scalar
nodes, which can't
reference anything else.
So another property that
values can have
are retaining paths.
And this is a path from the root
node to the value itself.
And so, every value can have one
or more retaining paths.
And if we look at the green
value on the graph, you can
actually see that there's one
retaining path that starts at
the root node and extends
along the red edge.
And there's a second retaining
that starts at the root node
and then extends along
these two red edges.
Both of these are retaining
paths for the green node.
It keeps the green
node in memory.
Without a retaining path, the
value becomes garbage.
And we'll get into
that in a moment.
So again, this is a fairly
basic operation.
But it's important to understand
exactly how you can
remove a value from the graph.
So if we want to remove the red
value from the graph, we
could cut this edge right here,
from the root node to
the first green node.
And then the red value
is garbage.
If we cut this edge,
it's also garbage.
Or we cut this edge.
Any of those three edges
cut would make
the red node garbage.
So what exactly is garbage?
Well, it's all values which
cannot be reached
from the root node.
Or said another way, it's
all values that
lack a retaining path.
If something doesn't have a
retaining path, then it
becomes garbage, like
these nodes here.
You'll see that there is no
path from the root node to
these values, so these values
are actually garbage.
At some point, they
were on the graph,
and now they're not.
And at the next garbage
collection process, they'll be
cleaned up, which actually
brings us to garbage
collection.
So the first step in a garbage
collection pass is to find all
the live values.
And then the second is to return
the memory used by the
dead values back to the system
so that they can be recycled
later on, as we see here.
So another property that every
value inside JavaScript has is
its retained size.
So the retained size, you can
conceptually think about this
as the amount of memory that
would be freed if the value
became garbage.
And so that's the size of
the value and all of its
descendants which lack
retaining paths.
So if we look at the yellow
node on the graph, its
retained size is its size plus
the size of the green node.
And if we pull back, the
retained sides of this new
yellow node is both of the green
node size plus itself.
And if we go all the way back to
the root node, the retained
size is all memory being
used by JavaScript.
So now let's talk
about a leak.
A leak is when you, the
programmer, have mistakenly
left a retaining path some
value inside the graph.
You think that the value has no
path, starting from a root
node, getting to it, and that
it'll be collected at the next
garbage collection cycle.
But you've accidentally
left a retaining path.
So it's a program error, as
all memory leaks are.
If we look at this really simple
example that's kind of
Gmail themed, we have an email
object and we have the message
field inside of it.
And we assign that to be
a div node in the dom.
We then want to display these
email messages, so we add that
div node into a display
list as well.
So this is what the object
graph looks like after
running this code.
Somewhere, starting at the root
node, there's paths to
both email and display.
And then off of email, there's
a path to message.
And there's a special
kind of edge from
message to the Div Node.
And this is pinning a native
object, an external object
that's not directly related
to JavaScript.
But this is the way it looks.
You follow the other path.
You go from display, and then
you have this list of div
elements, terminating with the
div node that we just created
on the previous slide.
LOREENA LEE: So everything
here, the green nodes are
JavaScript objects, and the
yellow are actual dom nodes?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
Yeah.
They're external to
the JavaScript.
So at some point later on,
we're done looking at
messages, and we want to just
clean out the display list.
So the programmer writes
removeAllChildren, Children
and you think, OK, all those
div nodes are gone.
But whoops, we've actually
cached a reference from the
message object to
the div node.
So until the email itself is
removed from the system, which
could take forever and might not
ever happen, this div node
will be pinned in memory,
and we've leaked it.
So in general, the really basics
of memory management in
JavaScript are that
the values are all
organized inside this graph.
And they have retaining paths.
And any value that
lacks a retaining
path has become garbage.
And then there's
retained sizes.
And that's the amount of memory
that you're going to
free up when the value itself
becomes garbage.
So let's go from the general to
the specific and talk about
the way V8 manages
memory and what
happens during a GC Pause.
The first question you want to
ask yourself is, what's the
cost in allocating memory
in JavaScript?
And it's not the call to new.
Typically, the call to new
is incredibly fast.
It's very, very quick, until
you've exhausted a memory
pool, and we'll get to
this in a moment of
what's actually happening.
But at that point, the runtime
is forced to do a garbage
collection.
And this is where all
the time is spent.
And it can actually
take milliseconds.
So if you're writing a game, you
have 16 milliseconds to do
everything inside
of your frame.
And a garbage collection pause
might pause your application
for 5, maybe 10 milliseconds,
which for Gmail might be OK,
but for some applications
it's really too long.
So it's important to be aware
at the pattern at which your
application is allocating
objects and understand how it
interacts with the garbage
collector.
And this is what we're going
to talk about right now.
V8 manages memory in
two generations.
There's the young generation and
then the old generation.
And by young and old, I mean
how long has the JavaScript
value existed for.
And over time, young values get
promoted to old values.
So after a few garbage
collections, if the value
survives, meaning that there's a
retaining path and it's kept
in memory, eventually the value
gets promoted into the
old generation.
So what are the properties of
the young generation in V8?
Well, it offers really fast
allocation, fast collection,
and it's frequently collected.
In fact, when you're using the
Timeline tool and you see the
GC Event on it, this is a young
generation collection.
In contrast, the old generation
offers fast
allocation, but the collection
is much slower.
The good thing is that it's very
infrequently collected.
And some of the old generation's
collection occurs
in parallel with your
page's execution.
Whereas a young generation
collection, is really just
everything is stopped, the
collection occurs, and then
your page resumes.
Old generation mixes a little
bit of collection with your
page's execution.
So I want to focus mostly on
young generation, because this
is where you're going to feel
the pain inside your
application.
And it's going to happen
fairly regularly.
It's important to understand
why collecting the young
generation is faster.
And intuitively, you have to
understand that the cost of
the GC Pause is actually
proportional to the number of
live objects.
And because the objects are
split into the young and the
old generation, the
young generation,
actually not much survives.
After a garbage collection,
most of the values in the
young generation
don't make it.
They have no retaining path,
because they were used just
briefly, and they're gone,
and they're not
really in the graph.
Whereas by their nature, objects
in the old generation
have survived quite
a long time.
So you can't expect that when a
collection is triggered for
the old generation
that many of them
are going to disappear.
So knowing that the cost of the
garbage collection pause
really comes down to the number
of live objects, it
becomes quite clear why
collecting the young
generations so much faster.
So let's look at the young
generation in action.
The young generation
is split into two
semispaces, equally sized.
There's the To Space
and the From Space.
The To Space is where values
that you allocate when your
page executes, like, new Foo,
it's coming out of To Space.
The From Space actually just
sits there not being used
until later on.
And we'll see what
happens with it.
So assuming that To Space
started off empty and your
page starts allocated
some objects.
It does new A and then new B,
new C, and new D. Everything
up until this point has been
really fast, and there's been
no interruption in your
page's execution.
But then, your page calls
new E. And actually,
it's just too big.
It doesn't fit into
the To Space.
We've hit that threshold where
we've moved incrementally
closer to this GC Pause,
and now we've
actually triggered it.
So what happens is new
E doesn't happen.
It's kind of paused.
So we're still in this state
where we just have A, B, C,
and D inside of our To Space.
The page is paused, everything
halts, and the
collection is triggered.
The first step in a young
generation collection is that
the From and the To Space
and just swapped.
The labels to them are
flipped internally.
And then the live values
are found.
And I'm not really going into
details about exactly how the
live values are found, but
this is the next step.
Everything that still has a
retaining path, still on the
graph is discovered and
marked for copy.
So you can see here that
A and C are marked.
And B and D have not been
marked, so they're garbage.
They're not going anywhere.
And then this is where most
of the time goes.
It's when the live values are
copied from the From Space to
the To Space.
So here we are.
We've done the copy.
We've done the collection.
We've just copied the live
objects from one
semispace to the next.
And the From Space is just
recycled at this point.
There's no other work
done to it.
It's just ready for use next
time there's a collection that
needs to happen.
At this point, your page
is resumed, and
the E object is allocated.
What you have to understand is
that each allocation moves you
closer to a collection.
And so, when Loreena was talking
earlier about this
trade-off between more memory
and performance, you start to
see why that doesn't hold
up inside JavaScript.
Because the more memory you use,
the faster you're going
to get to this pause, and that's
actually where you're
going to lose performance.
LOREENA LEE: Right.
And not only that, but the more
memory you're using, the
longer the pause will take.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
LOREENA LEE: The larger the
heap, the longer the
collection will take.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yep.
Exactly.
And so, when the collection
occurs, your
application is paused.
You get higher latency.
Let's say the user clicks,
and then right then
a collection occurs.
Well, the click isn't going to
register for a while, because
we've got to go and do
a big collection.
So this leads to dropped
frames and poor user
interaction, in general,
and unhappy users.
And unhappy users don't come
back to your site.
They'll go somewhere else
with better performance.
LOREENA LEE: All right.
So now we've heard a little bit
about what happens when
you have a GC Pause and
how it all works.
But let's see how we can now
take what we learned and apply
some tools and techniques to
figure out how we can fix it.
So I mentioned that we were
starting out from nothing in
Gmail, and we really had no
idea how problematic the
memory situation as.
We heard our colleagues telling
us on a daily basis
that they were having
lots of issues.
But we didn't know exactly.
So we wanted to start and take
some field measurements.
We wanted to know how bad
it was for all of you.
So we used the
performance.memory API.
And what we do is we take
measurements every 30 minutes.
We store them in our logs, we
aggregate them, and we can
graph them.
We can kind of see what's the
difference between our power
users, the 99th percentile,
versus our median and the
people who just spend a few
minutes a day here and there.
So what the performance.memory
API does is it
returns three values.
It tells you the jsHeapSizeLimit
which is the
total amount of memory available
for JavaScript.
So this is the upper limit.
And then it tells you the
totalJSHeapSize, which is the
amount of memory that has been
allocated so far, including
the free space.
So this is including memory that
has already been GCed.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So could you
predict an "I'm dead, Jim"
situation by seeing when
totalJSHeapSize hits the
jsHeapSizeLimit?
LOREENA LEE: Right.
Right.
As that totalJSHeapSize gets
closer and closer, you know
that at some point you're going
to trigger this out of
memory situation.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: OK.
LOREENA LEE: And then the third
value that returns is
the usedJSHeapSize.
And that tells you the amount
of memory that's
currently in use.
So this is the amount of memory
that's being used by
live objects in the graph.
We were taking these
measurements from a
select set of users.
Gmail has a lot of users, so
we were able to get quite a
bit of data from these users.
And what we did was
we took one user.
We just sort of followed
that user.
We took a user who we knew was
using a lot of memory, who was
nearing this upper limit,
and we followed
them for three days.
So we wanted to see what the
correlation was between the
memory data we were collecting
as well as the latency data we
were collecting.
And what we found a little bit
against what our common belief
of the performance versus
memory trade-off was.
What we found was that as the
user's heap memory footprint
grew, their client
side latencies
were increasing also.
So over to the right
of each of these
graphs is by day three.
By day three, their heap size
was getting very large.
It was well over a gig.
And their latencies, the
variance between of the
latencies as well as the actual
values of the latency
were much much, much higher.
And so, given what you've
just heard about garbage
collection, you can see that
once the heap was large, these
GC pauses were taking more
and more amount of time.
And so that's what you see is
happening in these latencies.
So some of those outliers were
probably several second long
garbage collection pauses.
And those are things that we
want to definitely avoid.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: So after seeing
this data, we were more
motivated than ever to get
things under control.
So we turned to the Chrome
Developer Tools.
And If you haven't used
the tools before--
I hope everyone in this room has
at least fiddled with them
a little bit-- they're really,
really powerful.
And they're getting better
and better every day.
When we were first starting
out, some of these tools
didn't really scale to
applications of Gmail size.
But since then, we've forged
a relationship with the
DevTools, and things
have gotten
much, much, much better.
Now we actually find that almost
anything we need to
answer to we can find
in the DevTools.
So to get to the DevTools, this
is what we affectionately
call the hot dog menu, the
three bars you see in the
upper right-hand corner of your
Chrome browser window.
The hotdog menu, Tools,
and Developer Tools.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's not
the hamburger menu?
LOREENA LEE: There's
hot debate.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: So once you open
up these tools, you'll see a
powerful set of tools.
Inside here, we have
a CPU profiler.
We have a heap profiler.
We have Timeline tools that can
tell you about your events
that are happening in your
page, such as the garbage
collection events.
Also, things like paint
time, rendering time.
All of these things you can
see in the DevTools.
There's an interactive
JavaScript console.
It can interact with
your application.
So they're really powerful.
But right now we're going to
talk about the part of the
DevTools that we use to diagnose
these memory issues.
The first thing I like to do is
go to the Memory Timeline.
And this is in the Timeline
panel of your DevTools.
And what you can do here is you
can see at the top there's
actually multiple tabs here.
There's an Events Timeline that
can show you the garbage
collection pauses, like the
screenshot you saw earlier.
And then here, we're
the Memory Panel
and the Memory Timeline.
At the top there, you
see the blue.
And that's overall memory.
And then down below, you have
the ability to see three
different counts.
And right now I only have the
dom node count enabled.
But you can see the document
count, the dom node count, and
the event listener account.
And so these will tell you over
the timeline you recorded
how many of each of these things
is currently live.
So what you do is you take an
action or a sequence of
actions that you identify
as possibly suspicious.
You think that there
may be a leak in
performing these actions.
You start the timeline.
You can perform these actions
a number of times.
And so in this case, we
performed them six times.
And then there's a little
garbage can
button at the bottom.
You can click that button, and
that'll force a full garbage
collection.
And if you suspect that this
action should not leave any
dom nodes behind but that
number of nodes is not
dropping back down to your
baseline, you have a pretty
good indication that
there's a leak.
So here we did the experiment
twice, just make sure.
And we see that each time we
forced a GC, that number of
dom nodes is not dropping back
down to the baseline.
So we're pretty sure
we have a leak.
This is an action that we've
identified that should be
clean, but it's obviously not.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: By clean, you
mean there should be nothing
in the graph afterwards?
LOREENA LEE: We expect that the
actions should not leave
behind any dom nodes.
We think that we've cleaned
up after ourselves.
So we obviously have not.
So now what?
I'm really excited to introduce
the Object Tracker.
And this is brand new.
This is currently only enabled
in Chrome Canary
that you can get now.
But you need to enable the
DevTools Experiments.
And we'll give you instructions
on how to do
that, DevTools Experiments, and
then the Object Tracker.
And this is really cool because
it combines the best
of both worlds.
This combines the timeline
functionality, like the one I
just showed, with the heap
profiler that is already
existing in current
stable channel.
And that heap profiler will tell
you all the objects that
are in the heap at
any given time.
When you collect a snapshot,
it'll show you everything
that's in the heap that's
live at a given time.
But here now, you can start
recording, and it'll take
snapshots periodically through
that recording.
And it'll tell you what objects
were live in that
recording at any given time,
or I should say, that were
allocated during that time.
So let's look a little
bit more in detail.
Here at the top, you see
some color-coded bars.
These identify new objects
that were found that were
allocated during the timeline.
So I said that we take periodic
snapshots while we're
doing this.
And as you take a snapshot, it
does a full profile snapshot,
heap profile.
And it'll look for new objects
that weren't there the
previous time.
So here, you see that there
are 10 bars, and there's
different colors.
The blue bars indicate new
objects that were found during
that time that are still live
at the end of the timeline.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: At the
end of the capture.
LOREENA LEE: At the end
of the capture.
So the end of this timeframe
that the whole
recording was taken.
The gray bars show that there
were new objects that were
found at that point in time,
but they've since
been garbage collected.
So by the end of the capture,
those objects that are in gray
now have been collected.
You can also narrow in on any
of those bars to get more
information about what exactly
was in that difference.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: And then down below
is the heap contents.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The heap
contents is connected to the
time window that you've
selected.
LOREENA LEE: Right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So it's only
going to show objects that are
alive that are within the time
range that you've picked.
LOREENA LEE: Right.
OK.
I know it's hard to tell from
screenshots, so you probably
want to see a demo.
Let's see.
So we wrote a simple mail-like
app, since we're talking about
Gmail here.
In Gmail, we cached messages
for better performance.
In this little demo, we have
a cache of size 5.
That means that, in theory, no
more than 5 messages should be
in memory at any given time.
So let's take a look.
OK.
So first we're going to start
off with our timeline.
And you see that I'm
on the memory here.
And let's go ahead and we'll
just look at dom node count to
not confuse ourselves.
And let's see.
I said we have a cache
of size 5.
One thing we should always
do is refresh.
Make sure you're starting
with a clean slate.
And we'll go ahead and read
those 5 messages.
So we've now filled
up our cache.
Let's read 5 more, and we'll do
a full garbage collection.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Are we going
to start recording?
LOREENA LEE: Oh, yes.
We do need to be recording.
OK.
So the cache is full.
Let's read 5 messages, let's
collect garbage, and let's
stop the recording.
So you see the blue bar at the
top shows you how much memory
is being used.
And we see this stairstep.
This is when I clicked
the next message.
You see there'll
be five steps.
And you know, I'm pretty sure
I clicked that garbage can
button, but I'm not seeing the
dom node count drop down.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: So let's try it
again, just to make sure.
I'll record.
Read 5 more messages.
Click that.
I'll expand it.
It's dropping down, but
not quite as far as
I expected it to.
I expected it to be down
to the baseline.
Our cache was already full, and
we've still got some dom
nodes here.
So now we're going to go over
to the Profile Panel, see if
we can figure out
what's going on.
Let's refresh, start
from the beginning.
So this new Object Tracker, the
last one here, it's called
Track Allocations.
So this will run the heap
profiler continuously and
collect these snapshots
periodically while we're
interacting with our app.
So we'll start this.
And let's go ahead and
read 10 messages.
7, 8, 9, 10.
And we'll go ahead
and stop it.
So once the snapshot is
loaded, we should
see these 10 bars.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
We know our cache is
of size 5, right?
So here we see the total.
Let's scroll this up so
you guys can see it
a little bit better.
So we see these last 5 messages
that we read, and
those are all blue.
So we know that these are still
objects that are live in
the graph at the end of this
whole timeline capture.
But now we have this one blue
bar, this third one
here, and it's blue.
I'm expecting that we only have
5 messages in our cache,
and I see that there's
something
strange going on here.
If we look at this message Aux
Data, which is our message
headers, we actually can
look here we can
see the object count.
And there's 6.
That confuses me, because I
expected that we had a cache
of size 5, so I don't know why
we still have this sixth
message that didn't
get collected.
So we can actually zoom in
on any of these bars.
And we can see exactly
the objects that were
found in the diff.
Basically, this is a diff
between this blue bar and the
previous snapshot.
We see that these objects
are still live.
They're showing up here because
they're still live in
the heap at the end of
this full timeline.
So if I look at one of
these first ones--
That's probably not a good one
because it's got some extra
code in there.
If I look at one of these here
that's all grey, we'll see
nothing here.
And this means that everything
that was found in this diff of
snapshot, this snapshot that
was taken here, any new
allocations here have since been
very garbage collected.
And that's what we expect.
But here we have this blue
bar, which confuses us.
So let's take a look.
We see that there's a message
Aux.Data here.
We have a html div element
that's sticking around.
And so we want to kind of see
what's retaining this.
What's the retaining path
to these objects?
So we see here that the
retaining path has this saved
messages array.
So this is index 0 in the
saved messages array.
And what we see here is that
we actually have some extra
array that's not a cache that's
holding on to this
extra message, and
that's causing
it to not be collected.
And so we can actually go back
to the source and look and see
what this saved messages array
is in this case and go ahead
and make sure that we free
that reference up.
And that will cause this
to get collected.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
You can use the view of the
retaining path down here as a
clue to where in your source
code this object was allocated
and where it probably should
be cleaned up.
LOREENA LEE: Right.
Right.
So that's the Object Tracker.
Let's go back and see was
this really worth it.
This is kind of a lot of work,
especially if you think about
an application of Gmail size.
The JavaScript is actually huge,
so going through and
performing these techniques
actually can take some time.
But was it really worth it?
And I'd say a resounding yes.
This is the data that we
collected using the
performance memory API that
I mentioned earlier.
This is actually a
graph of about a
10month period in 2012.
If you look far to the left,
you can see that memory was
actually really far
out of control.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And the
scale here is just
relative to the median?
LOREENA LEE: Right.
Well, it's relative to
itself, I guess.
Yeah.
So the green line on the bottom
is actually the median.
And the blue line up at the top
is the 99th percentile.
So the blue line represents
mostly our power users.
And you can see that for our
power users we've actually
reduced memory in this 10-month
period by 80%, or
more, actually.
And for our median users--
it's hard to tell on
this graph, just
because of the scale--
we actually reduced the amount
of memory that our median
users was using by over 50%.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Nice.
LOREENA LEE: And you'll
see there's these two
peaks on the blue line.
And they're there on the other
lines as well, but the scale
is not quite as obvious.
And what these are actually
showing us is two regressions
that we found that were in
Chrome itself, not in Gmail.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So you
found bugs in V8?
LOREENA LEE: We actually did
find some bugs in V8.
And then these particular
cases, they were
fragmentation bugs.
So the garbage collector was
actually collecting garbage,
but it was so fragmented and
in these tiny little chunks
that Gmail wasn't able to use
them for new allocations.
So what we noticed here was that
we mentioned there were
three values that are being
reported by the
performance.memory API.
One of them was totalJSHeapSize,
which was the
memory in use plus
the free space.
And then there was the
usedJSHeapSize, which was the
live objects.
And we noticed that the
gap between these
two lines was growing.
So that's how we've realized
that it wasn't actually a
Gmail problem that was causing
these two peaks.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: So once those were
fixed, we got things back
under control.
And we're in a pretty good
place right now.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Looks like it.
LOREENA LEE: Really, what we're
asking of everybody in
this room, and hopefully beyond,
is to think about how
your memory usage is affecting
your performance.
And we recall that the higher
the memory footprint, the
longer the latencies were and
the wider the variance.
And so, really, these
GC pauses can be
an performance killer.
So ask yourself these questions
about your app.
How much memory is
your page using?
Are you using an amount of
memory that is reasonable for
the size of your app?
If you have a small, not so
interactive app, and you're
using hundreds of megabytes of
memory, you're probably not
using things most efficiently.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Even for Gmail,
you were able to reduce
memory usage for the 99th
percentile by 80% without
impacting performance,
I imagine.
LOREENA LEE: Well, without
negatively impacting
performance.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
LOREENA LEE: We actually did
see a modest improvement in
our latencies.
And so it really does
make a difference.
For Gmail, latencies are
hard to tell sometimes.
But for the 99th percentile,
seeing a 10% improvement in
latency is a big deal for us.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: So is your
page leak-free?
When you first load your page,
versus after a day, after two
days, after a week, is
the memory staying in
a reasonable size?
Is it growing over time?
Or are you leaking memory
that you shouldn't be?
And how frequently
are you GCing?
We showed you some tools that
you can use to figure out how
frequently you are GCing and
if those GC pauses are
affecting your performance.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
If you're seeing a lot of GCs,
that probably indicates that
you're just allocating a ton of
objects inside JavaScript,
which you likely don't
need to be doing.
So that's just another indicator
that maybe there's a
different way to structure your
page or your site so that
the performance impact of
GCs can be lessened.
LOREENA LEE: Right.
And then we showed you
a bunch of tools.
The Chrome Developer Tools
really are getting better and
better every day.
We have some really great
documentation on
developers.google.com that
you can check out.
There's a lot of tutorials on
there that you can use to get
an introduction to
these tools.
We'll actually also be
publishing an article that
goes with this talk, so you can
get more information on
how to enable the Object
Tracker and try it out.
We'll also send you a
link to our demo, so
you can follow along.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
You can try this out yourself.
You can try the continuous
snapshot technique.
And the article will be
available next week.
LOREENA LEE: And then, there's
the heap profiler.
There's the Object Tracker
that we just showed.
And play around with
everything.
The Timeline is really cool.
You can see, really,
everything that
your page is doing.
When you refresh it,
you can see how the
page actually displays.
There's a lot of great talks
this week that you guys should
try to attend as many as you
can just to get more
information.
All right.
That's it.
Thank you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thanks,
everyone.
So for reference, there's a
link to the demo source.
You can just hit it
with your browser.
And here are the instructions
on how to enable this Object
Tracker today.
We can take questions.
And be sure to rate the
talk using the app.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Well, in an ideal world, your
application should not have
memory leaks.
But there's no ideal
world yet.
And so my question is, is it
possible to have some kind of
listener with JavaScript that,
once your application is about
to hit a memory leak, with
JavaScript you will know about
it, and instead of showing this
or that Jim page, you can
take some actions before
actually losing everything?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: For those of
you who couldn't hear, the
question was, could there be an
event channel that signals
that a memory leak
has occurred?
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: Is about to occur.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Or
about to occur.
Yes.
The issue with that is that
there is no way to know the
intention of the programmer.
V8 can't possibly conclude that,
oh, this reference in
the graph that's keeping this
value here is an error.
Because maybe you actually
intended that
reference to be there.
Although it would be nice to
maybe have some event channels
that tell you when you're
getting close--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah. --to the heap
size or something.
Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: You could
definitely have some sort of
listener that would poll this
performance.memory API and
sort of see that the limit
is being approached.
But there's not really any way
that you could say, hey, you
know, you've been holding onto
this thing for a long time.
Are you sure you wanted to?
That's actually really,
really tricky.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
OK.
OK, thanks.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So in terms of that
process that you guys went
through last year, obviously
the example you showed here
was ridiculously simple.
So there's kind of like, OK,
we have a memory leak.
What did you find were the
common actual sources of the
memory leaks, like the
coding patterns that
were causing them?
And in a code base like Gmail,
which is hundreds of thousands
of lines of code, how would
you just narrow it down?
You have these objects, but then
you need to know where
these objects are getting
allocated and where the bad
stuff is actually happening.
LOREENA LEE: Right.
So we had the heap profiler.
And the Object Tracker
is brand new.
So it would have been
really awesome to
have that last year.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
LOREENA LEE: That would have
made things a lot easier.
AUDIENCE: For sure.
LOREENA LEE: But using the
heap profiler, there's a
technique that you can take
multiple snapshots and compare
them to each other.
So we performed some actions,
and we saw that memory was
growing when we did something
as simple
as compose and discard.
If you compose a message and you
discard it, once the Undo
[? butterbar ?]
disappears, we really expected
that there should be nothing
left over from that action.
And so we could perform
something like that and then
do these comparisons between
multiple heap profiles, heap
snapshots, and see
what's lingering.
And in those cases, we could
find certain objects, and we
could look for those particular
objects that were
being left behind.
So that was one of them.
I would say we have a few
different categories of bugs
that we found.
One of them was things like
infinitely growing caches, so
things where we were saving
references to things that we
didn't mean to.
One case, we had a list of
callbacks that were supposed
to be invoked when a particular
action occurred.
And that action never occurred,
so we had an
infinitely growing list
of callbacks.
There was also a bunch of
cases where we had event
listeners attached to
particular objects.
And the event listener
was acting as a
reference on those objects.
The reason why I didn't
mention it here
is the Closure team--
we use the Closure Compiler--
they've gone through some really
amazing hoops to try to
eliminate this particular
coding problem.
And so if you do use Closure and
you do have this problem
where you have event listeners
that are causing references to
particular objects sticking
around, newer versions of
Closure should eliminate
that problem for you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great, thanks.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What would be the
ideal size for the young space
to avoid frequent GC pause?
How would you determine that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, the ideal
size would be infinite.
You could just have it
grow forever, and
you'd never GC pause.
It's actually very difficult to
find that sweet spot of a
practical number.
So that's a difficult
question.
There's not a straightforward
answer to it, I suppose.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if I can actually
tack this on.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: In the GC pause that
you showed, freeing up two
objects had enough room for E.
If there wasn't enough room
for E, in that case would
that flush to old?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No.
Young generation.
Collection occurs without an
old generation collection.
AUDIENCE: But if the flushing
two objects didn't have enough
room for E?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, I see.
Yeah.
At that point, you would fall
back to we have to do a full
collection and try
and free memory.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Good.
Thanks.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thanks.
Yeah.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: So some of the graphs
you showed with the
Gmail performance with the
different percentiles, that's
actually awesome.
So do you have any tips for
building tools like that?
Are there any tools that you
know of that can help monitor
your users in production?
LOREENA LEE: You can actually
just call the
performance.memory API
from your application
at any given time.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And that's for memory
and UI latency as well?
LOREENA LEE: The latency is a
totally separate tracker.
We have a separate tracker.
We're actually out of
time, but we're
happy to stick around.
We'll probably head upstairs
to the Chrome
office hours area.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So anyone who
still has questions, you can
just meet up upstairs in like
10 minutes, and we'll take
questions there.
LOREENA LEE: But the short
answer is that latency we
track completely separately.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thank
you, everyone.
LOREENA LEE: Thank you.